911 was the worst ever terrorist attack
on u.s soil five prisoners in guantanamo
bay are accused of helping kill
thousands of americans twenty years
after the attack they're still waiting
to go on trial catherine harris spoke
with a woman whose fiance was killed in
9 11. melissa long has visited
guantanamo to push for a trial she calls
it a case of justice delayed justice
denied
he was a firefighter we just had a very
different connection than anybody i'd
ever been with before and i truly loved
him melissa long is describing her
fiance brian sweeney who gave an
interview just before 9 11 about landing
his dream job with one of the most
storied firehouses in new york city
rescue one everyone gives us a lot of
respect because they always see us
running into the burning buildings
because everyone else is leaving i see
your face completely light up when you
talk about brian he makes me happy i
would never people like would you have
rather have never met him absolutely not
on 9 11 brian got the call to the world
trade center i personally had a sense
like that first night that he was gone i
just felt this emptiness in my heart
two weeks later the red cross took
melissa to the still smoldering ground
zero they show you the pile and
you could smell it
you know i think it was their way of
telling us that he was gone
it took 76 days for rescue teams to find
brian sweeney they identified him by his
tattoos
in total
343 new york city firefighters were
killed on 9 11. i stood there and i said
god didn't do this people did
melissa sought justice for brian at the
military courts in guantanamo bay cuba
it's not about people who are saying
they're innocent the five 911 suspects
including the self-described architect
of the attacks khalid sheikh mohammed
are stuck in legal limbo i really do
believe they should have their day in
court and i want my day in court and i
want to hear the evidence defense
attorney edward mcmahon jr represented 9
11 al-qaeda suspect walid binatash who
is accused of working directly with
al-qaeda leader osama bin laden what
explains
a delay of two decades the military
courts are unable to handle these trials
in any efficient manner whatsoever
they've never had a complex death
penalty case with multiple defendants in
2009 president obama's effort to bring
the defendants to trial in new york city
failed yet from the very beginning
defense attorneys say there's been a
government secret so closely held that
has paralyzed the court i don't think
the cia would care if this trial never
went forward
before the 9 11 defendants got to
guantanamo the bush administration held
them in c.i.a secret prisons where they
were interrogated using extreme tactics
that critics called torture to this day
the program remains highly classified
did you see evidence that showed your
client at the time had been tortured in
cia custody no i can't answer that
question is it a classification issue
i'm trying to think how to say this i
don't get arrested but i don't believe
the agency itself has ever conceded that
it occurred and certainly have never
conceded that they tortured anybody who
has the power to say enough is enough to
end this
president of the united states my
prediction is that the 9 11 defendants
will die of natural causes in gitmo
before there's a trial
have the families been let down
yeah i mean for sure nobody cares about
the trials there's no political will i
guess you'd say for that to happen and
that's a shame
a spokesman for the military trials
tells cbs news the cases are complex and
they are committed to a fair and just
outcome but offered no timeline the bind
administration wants to close the
guantanamo detention camp scale
catherine thank you she raised some
interesting questions there 20 years
does seem a very long time you know it's
a good interview
the person you're talking to says let me
see how i can say this without getting
arrested yes right and when you don't
have answers you're constantly reminded
of the pain and we need those answers
that is something that president biden
could do and you're right a whole lot
more to that story come